continues to bombard civilian
neighborhoods as over a million
ukrainian refugees have now fled the
country let's go to the big board now
with special report anchor bret baer
brett hey jesse just in the past few
minutes crossing the wire
the nuclear power plant one of the
biggest in europe the biggest in ukraine
zaprzya right here
the plant manager is saying that they
are coming under shelling
at that nuclear power plant and that is
a big big deal forces as you heard
earlier surrounding maripol here and you
heard from the deputy mayor in your
broadcast they've taken over kerasan
here and basically controlling this area
however this
right here is a major development in
fact just in the past few minutes the
international atomic energy agency the
iaea the director general said that the
situation was critical and called on the
russian military to stop attacking
a nuclear power plant now we saw this
concern with chernobyl up in the uh in
the north and west but this is in a
really tough situation i'm going to go a
little closer here if i can
to this area this um
this is exactly where the
where the power plant is right here
and
you know the possibility uh for a lot of
negative things happening with shelling
of a nuclear power plant uh you can
imagine
this area along the coast and odessa is
the next
we think
goal for the russian forces they are
surrounding maripol and trying to
control as you mentioned earlier
this southern portion
as you go around the country up towards
kiev
we've had the bombardment here
in the city itself we've heard from our
guys that convoy we continue to talk
about right here and getting supplied by
uh a base in belarus but not moving and
it's definitely one of the biggest
targets you can ever see in a war
situation and some of them have been
taken out as you were talking about from
from drones and from ukrainian air
air efforts but it just has not moved
this convoy and it's it's coming close
it's about 15 20 miles
outside the center of kiev
but the thought is is that eventually
they will resupply and try to circle
each one of these big cities and then
continue to bombard if it goes as the
playbook in past russian uh efforts have
gone in grazny in syria
and other places jesse thanks so much
brett and as i said we have a special
report later in the show we've received
some intelligence as to why that convoy
has slowed down so
stay with prime time thank you all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else